social conservatism was really bringing
me down and I realized this as time went
on I wasn't a bush conservative I was
really a libertarian our motto here is
the alternative maintenance when with
dick we've been saying it for years
Christianity makes you feel guilty
first so does the environmental movement
it makes you feel or Petersons an
economy you're not a woman
you're hearing a lizard walking around
with a stolen genital it's actually
persecuted in an article for not being
enough of a feminist because I stood up
for individuals right hi i'm tim
cavanaugh for Reason TV we are here with
Kennedy America's Sweetheart TV and
radio icon and currently morning host at
98 7 FM in LA that's right welcome
Kennedy well thank you Tim Cavanaugh
it's wonderful to be here I'm a huge fan
of reason in reason TV your
self-described libertarian yeah known as
a conservative back in the day so let's
talk a little bit about your your own
political evolution well it's it's like
being bisexual but everyone pinned you
is gay and then you realize like no wait
I'm so much more complex than that
I'd really like to sample from a greater
section of the menu and that's and I
realized because the social conservatism
was really bringing me down and I
realized as time went on I wasn't a bush
conservative I was really a libertarian
and I realized that fairly early at MTV
through my own political
self-exploration and it's it's wonderful
to have come out as a libertarian no
else don't the thing that's been
bothering you lately is the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco Firearms and Explosives
new rules around California medical
marijuana users can you explain quickly
what the new yeah you know what the new
rulemaking is I'm not sure we can even
call it a rule because it seems to be
totally unlike you know it's it's a
suggestion but it puts gun sellers in a
really bad position because
you know here they are sandwiched in
between this federal suggestion from the
ATF and the state laws which say that
people in California because of
proposition 215 and 1996 The
Compassionate Use Act people can possess
cultivate go to marijuana dispensaries
if they have a legitimate prescription
they can go in and get medical marijuana
but now the ATF is telling gun sellers
do not sell guns to these people because
they are using illicit drugs because
it's still illegal on the federal level
it seems to me the ATF does not have the
authority to give such an order but I
mean it's at this point it had none of
it has been litigated or anything like
no I mean it's criminal it's insane yeah
and and you can't just take aspects of
the Constitution and modify them
willy-nilly to fit what you think is a
correct moral purpose it hasn't gotten a
lot of attention I don't know that the
LA Times even write anything about it I
didn't read about it and the only times
I read about it in the SAC be that's one
of those those areas where nobody in the
media cares if nobody's I get a guy want
to get done Yeah right this is not just
for dispensary owners but this is
actually the techies work for Eric
Holder and the rest of the United States
government to funnel weapons to Mexican
drug lords that's okay yeah but God
forbid law-abiding citizens in this
country would want to have the choice to
protect themselves
yeah you were part of was it the second
generation of VJ it's actually called
the third wave because we the second the
first generation was Northglenn Martha
JJ Jackson Mark Goodman Alan hunter
Nina Blackwood and then the second wave
was Adam Curley Kevin Steele downtown
Julie brown and the redheaded Julie
brown and then my generation it was Bill
Bellamy John Senseo Daisy Fuentes Jenny
McCarthy I was in there okay
there was a little-known comic from New
York who was a VJ for a summer at the
MTV beach house this guy was completely
broke and he used to go out to the beach
house even when he wasn't scheduled to
work just so he could stay somewhere for
free and eat free food his name was John
Stewart I don't know if you
ever heard of that I have heard of that
yeah no and I remember him I you know
for years I continued to associate him
with MTV after he had sort of become
famous for other stuff you were kind of
a controversial person at the time you
were at one point voted the most hated
VJ I believe you haven't currently a 63%
on am i annoying so is great yeah I mean
how much of that was political because
it did seem even I I was you actually
hit an MTV when I was in my too good for
TV of any kind mode but uh you know I
got the sense that it was like it
surrounded by books exactly yeah yeah
exactly
it was sort of controversial to be you
know in favor of the Republicans ya know
it really was and and it was something
that was cute until it became more
serious and for example in 1996 the dole
campaign reached out to me at the end of
the campaign because they right before
the election they were doing the 96
hours to victory tour and so they were
kind enough to invite me on the private
plane and those who didn't know within
his inner circle who didn't know that I
had been invited thought that I was part
of the liberal press trying to
infiltrate and a woman tried to
physically block me from getting on the
plane with chi-chi Rodriguez and the
Oakridge boys and then she realized oh
no wait she's one of us fantastic yeah
and but when that happened
MTV they kind of cracked down and and
there was actually I was the only person
who had a clause in my contract that I
had to get Network approval before I
uttered a word about politics to the
press when you think about working in
the entertainment industry and we're in
LA right now why is it so hard and to
some extent I think conservatives might
exaggerate how you know tough it is to
have different politics yeah Hollywood
but what what's your own impression well
clearly I'm a minority and I'm also a
woman and also a conservative or
libertarian however you'd like to
identify that's fine you know it's it's
your choice
and of all of those things being
conservative is the most professionally
damning you have to work much
harder against that type because there
are people who will truly discount your
your talent your ability your
connections your persistence
they will discount all of that if they
think that you do not fit into a certain
political box yeah because if if you are
a liberal you're in you know there is
something implicit there is an implicit
trust in there and if you are outside of
that it means that you're difficult or
you're an evangelical you've been in the
alt-rock universe most of your career
right you were your alternative nation
98 7 is it's you know what is still
known as alternative rock yeah that that
sort of came out of Punk it's a you know
I mean lately it sort of either was Punk
and then what was known as college rock
the late 80s of like firehose and all
these kinds of bands talk a little bit
about the politics of the alternative
universe Danny Elfman these days
describes himself as a Democrat but if
you listen to early on go Boingo it was
all full of these songs of capitalism
and only a lad that were super
right-wing songs sang with s OD
stormtroopers and death I mean you could
argue that they were very conservative
yeah so what where did you what do you
think of politics of all alt-rock as
opposed to you know just sort of top 40
or what they were reacting against which
was just kind of you know 70s school
type rock it's really interesting
because I think a lot of the
intellectuals in that genre are are
iconoclasts and you know the icons and
rock are leftist and they don't even
want to be pigeonholed there because
it's very boring like you don't want to
be told what you are you don't want to
be defined by someone else based on what
your peers may think so it's it's much
more fun to shoot down everything you
know whether it's corporations or the
government and you know the government
is the man if if you're talking about
intrusive government it's like you're
automatically a libertarian what's the
current state of all rock well it's
interesting because kids think that
music is free now and that's a problem
because you know with Spotify and all
the different apps and programs that
there are
and websites you can essentially listen
to whatever you want at any time for
free and not a lot of people buy music
people will talk about buying music in a
self reverential way the same way they
talk about writing handwritten letters
like well actually buy my music is like
wow what a fine upstanding citizen you
are so a lot of bands offer free
downloads of their record but then
they'll sell them for you know name your
own price Radiohead is done at 9 - nails
has done it plenty of vans have done it
and they've realized that DIY which is
the old punk-rock model you know minor
threatened Fugazi that was the way that
a lot of the DC bands operated for a
long time and it's the only way anyone's
going to make money you have to own your
own content you have to own your own
music you have to be in charge of the
vertical integration of your
you